- Marketing and running a business
is about having a good deal on your media,
spend your efforts and your
time, not if something's--
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Hey vlog, this Sasha group thing
is just gonna be really fun.
Like, the great pleasure
of my professional career
was helping build a
business for my parents.
Obviously in the micro of that
was building a small business.
And guess what, building Vayner
Media's a small business,
zero to 200 million,
that's a small business.
It's really hard to help small businesses
spend a 100,000 a year
'cause they're scared
shitless to spend 100,000.
It is a lot to spend when you're like
taking home 80,000 in your salary
but a lot of them are spending 72,000
on Google and direct
mail and the Yellow Pages
and the Chamber of Commerce
and all this stuff that,
it's not dead, it's just not a good deal.
Gonna make a little clip here
but you can keep in the vlog.
There's a big difference
between something being dead
and something not being a good deal.
The actions you're running
your business with,
whether it's Yellow Pages or direct mail
or even Google AdWords for a lot of people
is not a good deal
anymore as it used to be.
To me when I think about marketing
or what I'm about or why I'm pushing you
to post organic content
on Instagram right now
and run ads on Instagram is
'cause I think in nine years
Instagram's not gonna be a good deal.
It'll still be here, guess
what, Myspace is still here.
Marketing and running a business
is about having a good deal on your media,
spend your efforts and your time,
not if something's dead or alive.
This is in the margins,
this is in the arbitrage.
Is it worth it today, February, 2019?
Are your actions worth it today?
Or did they work in 2003
and you're just on that repetitive shit.
♪ Beat business in your ear ♪
("Dream" by Nevrmind)
♪ I got a dream, fuck I just say ♪
♪ Better for Lee, drip on fleek ♪
♪ I got dream, yeah yeah, I got a dream ♪
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuck,
CEO and founder of VaynerX,
Anda Gansca, CEO and founder of Knotch,
and Stacy Taffet, Vice President
of Hydration Marketing at Pepsi.
- Thanks, thanks for having us.
So, from my standpoint it's
like, why wouldn't you use tools
that are available to you
to drive your business?
Social to me is a slang term
for the current state of
where people spend their
time on the internet,
which is all about attention, right,
like what's the purpose of these ads?
Like, awareness or attention is,
that's the best part about
the Superbowl, right?
It is going to get consumed,
whether on YouTube the week before,
whether during the game,
whether the next day,
this is going to get
consumed, so that's exciting.
I actually think brands
should really consider
not showing it on YouTube, like,
for five years I was all
about showing it on YouTube
and now I'm wondering if for
next year maybe they shouldn't
because some of the surprise elements
are being eliminated during the game
and I'm just kind of like
feeling like, is this the moment?
Like, is this a tipping point
where you want to pull back?
But it all leads to the
biggest punchline which is,
these are businesses that
are trying to drive business
and this is one of the
opportunities at their disposal.
This is a cultural event,
we're having an event,
a business event, around it.
We don't do that for the Grammys
or the Oscars or the NBA Finals.
So to me, what do I think about it?
I think anybody who doesn't have a robust
strategy to do creative
and media amplification
on the platforms that
dominate our mobile devices
is in outer space in 2019.
- Does creative really matter, you know,
for the the Super Bowl?
- Creative is the variable of success.
Did it inspire or make you think
that you want to consider
and then buy these products?
So, you know, a lot of people know
that I have a big passion
for volume of content,
quantity, which our industry
believes means not quality
which I think is silly,
but I, for the whole decade
that I've been in this industry,
continue to preach that the
creative is the variable
so yes, I do believe it.
- Super Bowl ads, one final point, Gary.
- Buy them.
(laughs)
♪ They don't wanna mess with me ♪
♪ I told 'em that carefully, ♪
♪ I swear they be testin'
me, pull up in that 'Rari ♪
- Solid day, this was fun.
Always love talking about advertising.
Excited to see how you
post produce it, brother.
Welcome, welcome, officially and
we'll see tomorrow, it's what we do.
Hey guys, thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all
please go to EmpathyWines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me,
I could really use your support.
("Dream" by Nevrmind)